hi we're here with Tom Bergeron a senior
user researcher in Google search thank
you for joining us thanks for having me
so what is user research user research
is a discipline that is providing
insights keyword insights into product
users their perspectives and abilities
to the right people at the right time so
that's the official definition to make
it more understandable user research is
there to help answer three big questions
the first one is what do people need the
second is what do people want which is
different than what they need and the
third one is can they use the thing that
we're working on whatever the thing is
is using research only for new ideas no
otherwise I wouldn't have a job you
start you have a new idea you validate
or invalidate it there are tons of
decisions an entrepreneur is making
about their product every day I'm not
saying all of them should be covered by
user research but it's not just for for
new ideas if you have if you want to
develop you we all do we have new ideas
for new features and how to improve the
product some of them may involve again a
lot of work so for those things that may
involve a lot of work I would try and
find out if they're worth it is it again
is it a problem worth solving or a
feature or a feature yes definitely so
how do I move from user research to
decisions so in order for you to make
decisions you first need to know what
about and that leads me to how do we
start how do we start the process of
users the first thing you need to do is
make it very clear for yourself and for
your team what is a the question that
we're trying to answer so if you want to
move after you did your research if we
want to move to making decisions you
first need answers to those questions
right that you've started with what
happens in many cases is that you have
answers to questions that you didn't ask
you didn't know to how to ask or you
weren't even aware that
there are questions that's fine but if
you have if you want to start with
research the first thing you need to do
is make a list of the questions you're
trying to answer what are the questions
that we will have answers to by the end
of this research this research effort
will fail if we don't have answers to
these questions so I write a list of all
the assumptions yes yes assumptions is a
perfect way to describe it an assumption
can easily be translated into a question
and it doesn't have to be long you know
sometimes one to three questions it's
perfectly fine okay so as soon as you're
done with research you should have
answers those answers can help you make
decisions I always start with my teams
when my team and I are trying to start a
research effort I always try to identify
where is this coming from why why why
are we talking now so and I'm trying I'm
doing that because I'm trying to
understand what is the question that
we're trying to answer so I'm looking
for dilemmas that people that people or
teams have arguments that they have I
attend a lot of meetings and I just
watch sometimes we have data that we
can't explain why is this happening and
and things like that so this can be
translated into answers questions and
then answers and these answers would
lead us to making decisions